On January 3rd 1999 a man named Andrew
Goldstein wandered on to this New York
City subway platform and shoved a
stranger named Kendra Webb Dale into the
path of an oncoming train with the story
making national news reporters dug into
Goldstein's past and found that he had
been diagnosed with schizophrenia and
had a history of violent episodes he had
been in and out of psychiatric
facilities but his caretakers repeatedly
released him back into the streets
against their better judgment because of
a shortage of available beds the murder
of Kendra Webb Dale brought attention to
our inability to provide adequate
treatment to Americans with severe
mental health problems which twenty
years later is still ongoing prisons and
jails are filled with inmates exhibiting
symptoms of mental illness and in need
of treatment many of the homeless people
crowding the streets of cities like Los
Angeles San Francisco and New York are
mentally ill and in need of care and
violence episodes like the murder of
Kendra Webb Dale have brought renewed
calls to bring back one of America's
most controversial institutions the
mental hospital and to entrust the state
with more authority to force psychiatric
care on patients against their will some
psychiatrists and bioethicists have
proposed bring back the psychiatric
hospital you know the old days we had
mental institutions and you could NAB
somebody like this because you know they
did they knew he was something resolved
the parents of mentally ill patients are
among the most vocal advocates they shut
down all the hospitals because oh we
have all these medicines now and
everybody came to be in recovery well
the unfortunate fact is not everybody
recovers so where do they go what do
they do so is it time to bring back the
asylum and why did it disappear in the
first place my contention is that there
is no mental illness and there can be no
mental illness in the mid 20th century
the libertarian psychiatrist Thomas saws
first articulated a theory that would
rock the profession and define his
career the
whole concept of mental illness was a
fraud homicides was a psychiatrist who
didn't really believe in psychiatry
having a book by him on your shelves
enough to start an argument
Jacob Selim interviewed saws for a
reason magazine in 2000 and cites him as
a major influence on his own work he
argued what people call mental illness
is not a literal disease but a
metaphorical disease what he called
problems in living internal conflicts
with yourself conflict with other people
you could ask people to define mental
illness and no one could one can only
give examples of it like homosexuality
which the American Psychiatric
Association voted that it's no longer a
disease it's only a disease if you don't
like it at the time the jaws was writing
lots of people were locked up who pose
no danger to other people and possibly
not even dangerous to themselves in any
way and might be subjected to what today
look like horrifying treatments but at
the time are considered to be the height
of science
here the skull is thin enough to
transmit light and it can usually be
perforated easily with a sharp
instrument without damage to any
important structure but the man who
discovered lobotomy and got the Nobel
Prize did it on people who didn't want
to be lobotomised tens of thousands of
Americans were subjected to lobotomy did
they want to be lobotomised lobotomy if
you take a sharp object and stick it up
through somebody's eye socket and jiggle
around their brain this person who used
to be troublesome and disruptive will
calm down often maybe will you end up
with somebody who now is less
troublesome to other people but is
impaired for the rest of his life and
you look back and you think how could
that have happened like how did they
think that that was a legitimate medical
treatment that was the context saws
helped to inspire the
deinstitutionalization movement that
started in the 1950s and hit its stride
in the 60s the time has come for a great
national effort nearly half of the five
hundred and thirty thousand persons in
our state mental hospitals are in
institutions with over 3,000 patients
getting little or no individual
treatment many of these institutions
have less than half of the professional
staff required forty-five percent of
them have been hospitalized for 10 years
or more if we launch a broad new health
program now it will be possible within a
decade
to reduce the number of patients now
under custodial care by up to 50% mental
hospitals started emptying out and
closing down but critics say de
institutionalisation was a disaster
dumping thousands of mental patients
onto the streets with no plan even sahs
criticized the way de
institutionalisation unfolded he thought
it sort of doubled the injustice that
those people were not offered the choice
to stay this is their home they're being
thrown out of now so he thought that was
wrong the number of psychiatric hospital
beds available dropped by 95% between
1955 and 2005 according to the treatment
Advocacy Center starting in 1960 is the
mental health population in hospitals
declined the number of mentally ill
people in jails and prisons shot up a
2011 Supreme Court case filed against
the California Bureau of Prisons
revealed that some mentally ill inmates
were held in telephone booths sized
solitary cells some reformers say it's
time to cast aside Thomas oz and his
attack on the mental health
establishment I gotta say toss has been
totally disproven it's kind of like
believing the Church's teachings on an
earth centric universe
DJ Jaffe first became aware of the
enormous problems in America's mental
health system after his sister-in-law
was diagnosed with schizophrenia and it
proved enormously challenging to get her
the treatment she needed my
sister-in-law thought that people across
the street we're talking about her
the FBI planted a transmitter in her
head there are a section of the mental
health industry that believes being
psychotic and delusional is a right to
be protected rather than an illness to
be treated being psychotic and
delusional is not an exercise of free
will it's the inability to exercise free
will and medications can free people
from the Bastille of their psychosis and
enable them to engage in society Jaffe
says that saws did offer a valid
critique of overreach and overdiagnosis
in the mental hell
industry there are pieces of these anti
psychiatrists which are true when you
talk about somebody with mild depression
mild ADHD is it so abnormal as to be
classified as a disorder and we are
certainly over diagnosing and
medicalizing that group people have
gotten the sense that he had a good
critique at the time but it's sort of it
really isn't outmoded I mean if anything
the territory claimed by psychiatry is
expanding more and more look at all the
other things that are covered by the
Diagnostic and Statistical Manual which
is a psychiatric Bible right but when it
comes to the four percent of the
population that the National Institute
of Mental Health characterizes as having
a serious mental illness Jaffe says
healthcare professionals need far more
power to involuntarily commit patients
to dedicated treatment centers the civil
commitment law is not good enough it
basically requires someone to become
danger to self or others we should
prevent people from becoming danger to
self or others not require them to
become danger to self or others
Jeffie also advocates for a policy
called assisted outpatient treatment New
York passed Kendra's law in November
1999 after Goldstein's murder of Kendra
Webb Dale it allows a judge to order
outpatient treatment for anyone with the
psychiatric diagnosis who's recently
been jailed or hospitalized as a result
of going untreated and who the court
determines will likely deteriorate
further without intervention and I would
suggest that it is a libertarian dream
it is lowered rates of homelessness
arrests incarceration needless
hospitalization in the 70% range for the
most seriously mentally ill and from a
libertarian perspective they maintain
more of their freedoms than the
alternatives which are inpatient
commitment or incarceration this idea
that we should just abandon the
seriously mentally ill who don't
recognize their need for treatment
serves neither the liberty interest of
the individual the financial interest of
xiety or the interests of trying to keep
the public safe when you're trying to
get help for someone especially for
misty who didn't feel like she needed
help it's very very difficult
Linda Mayo who lives in Modesto
California has been advocating for the
enactment of Laura's law in her home
county she's the mother of twin
daughters both with severe mental
illnesses and it's through their
experiences that she became an advocate
for strengthening the involuntary
commitment and compulsory treatment laws
it's not a panacea it's not gonna help
everyone but the people who refuse
treatment and consistently refuse
treatment and who are in and out of the
hospital in and out of jail homeless
suicidal it can help them Mayo believes
that the legal obstacles to involuntary
commitment could have cost her daughter
her life one day five years ago misty
who was 38 and has schizoaffective
disorder vanished
Mayo discovered that after collecting
her $200 paycheck she had boarded a bus
to Los Angeles I was frantic it was in a
big city that she was unfamiliar with
and we had no family or friends there
very little money I thought $200 that's
gonna go fast she had already been
sleeping in the parks here before she
left and roaming the streets so I
thought in LA it scared me more another
week and a half went by finally the
phone rang it was LAPD she was in a
neighborhood and sitting on a cliff and
the neighbors were concerned about her
in the mayor's view misty posed a threat
not only to herself but to others as
well
Mayo later found out that during the
time she was missing misty had been
arrested in a shopping mall I can't tell
you what was going through her head but
she was trying to take a baby out of a
baby carriage and the mother said no and
misty didn't heed that so she was
arrested for years misty had been
refusing therapy and medication
to her arrest the state had legal
grounds for forcing her to comply with
treatment Linda believes this saved
Misty's life I was very happy that she
was being allowed to be in the hospital
for a longer period of time that would
require some stabilization Laura's law
in her view creates a legal path to
giving seriously mentally ill patients
like misty the help they need before
they pose a danger to themselves or
others this is one step saying okay we
want to catch you in a court order
before it's a crime before it's a
hospitalization before it's homelessness
but some mental health advocates say
that Laura's law and similar bills
violate the rights of even seriously
mentally ill patients there's a big
perception in my community that once
they get their claws on you just like
law enforcement they're not letting you
go of they can help Richard Cruiser now
ski who himself has suffered from severe
depression is a patient's rights
advocate who has worked for LA County
representing mentally ill individuals
committed against their will some of the
most disempowering and dangerous words
anyone can say is we're doing this for
your own good you know we're here to
help you but if I'm not asking for help
when you see somebody walking down the
street screaming I am the Messiah it's
not because they think they're the
Messiah they know they're the Messiah
they are unaware that they are ill and
we should be delivering treatment to
them but Christian hausky says that
mental health professionals and
reformers often abuse the concept of too
sick to know you're sick to violate the
rights of the mentally ill it's a way of
saying I don't have to listen to you or
more to the point you're now voiceless
the whole involuntary treatment is a
hard balance and no one wants
involuntary all the advocates that I've
talked to that this is the last thing
that we want but there are cases that
require it and Christian aus key says
that even though the state institutions
are gone to this day many psychiatric
patient
are locked in facilities for weeks or
even months at a time under court orders
giving legal power over financial and
healthcare decisions to a third party
under an arrangement called
conservatorship the most difficult calls
we would get especially during anybody's
holiday season would be people who are
on conservatorship were locked away
somewhere they were able to get a phone
call and you just felt like you were
talking to one person alone like they
had them locked away in a dungeon and
hadn't seen the light for like months
another problem with the idea of
bringing back state mental hospitals is
that in the current system commitment
often exacerbate symptoms a study
published in the medical journal
psychiatric services found that
alarmingly high numbers of patients
admitted to one state-run mental health
system witnessed traumatic events were
secluded or restrained and even suffered
physical assault we can change the whole
historic dynamic of the use of coercion
in people with serious mental illnesses
psychiatrist Scott Zeller is the founder
of the Alameda model a movement
dedicated to reforming how mental health
institutions operates it focuses on
getting psychiatric patients out of
hospital emergency rooms as quickly as
possible and into dedicated mental
facilities that respect their right to
personal space and freedom even if
they've been involuntarily committed
typically if you're in a psychiatric
emergency you're very paranoid or you're
very frightened or you're very
despondent or you're very anxious and
imagine going into the general ER with
those kind of symptoms and basically
being put into a small space and said
you're gonna have to stay here and you
can't move and then people tend to get
worse in the ers the Providence Medical
Center in San Pedro California which
uses Zellers approach is a standalone
building just down the road from a
hospital
unlike in hospitals which are often
lacking in on-call psychiatrists staff
are able to medicate and stabilize
patients around the clock sometimes
through the use of telepsychiatry if a
doctor isn't on site with the goal of
discharging them for outpatient
treatment within the first 24 hours of
admission people
and move about nobody's telling him get
back in that corner what we find is the
vast majority of the time these folks
are going to get better within 10 15 20
hours tops and the idea that we were
holding them for three days to send them
to a hospital makes so little sense when
you're thinking we could have had them
on the same day the average psychiatric
emergency patient in a general medical
ER it may be 25 to 50 percent of them
will end up being physically restrained
leather restraints around wrists ankles
in an empath unit we're talking about
far less than 1% people respond very
well to a supportive interactive
nurturing environment not so much to a
coercive cold environment go figure
a social deviation these in the province
of Medicine Zeller says there's one
lesson from Zod's that family members of
the seriously mentally ill should
internalize there's no level of coercion
that can force some patients to conform
with societal norms as long as they
don't pose a danger to themselves or
others in some cases the best path
forward is acceptance if somebody says I
want to live on a tent downtown pretty
much you have to let them it's really
really difficult to determine when you
should leave that they no longer have
the right to decide for themselves I
think that we should be overly safe on
the side of protecting individual rights
I can't have pictures up in my house of
when they were babies and junior high
and high school and college it's the
shine the light in their eyes that I
miss that sense of joy and fun and
happiness is out of the eyes and that
makes me really sad
[Music]
you
[Music]